ومدينه باخ موته التي تحدث عنها مراسلنا
قبل قليل لا زالت عصيه على الجيش الروسي
وهذا الاستعصاء جعل الانتقادات التي
تحدثنا عنها تزيد للمسؤولين الروس الذين
باتوا مطالبين بتوضيح الحقائق للمواطنين
وللجنود يبديني بريكوزين رئيس مجموعه
الروسيه خرج ليبرر للجنود اسباب الفشل حتى
الان في الاستيلاء على مدينه
ليست بالسهله في بخمض في ظل التحصين الجيد
للجيش للجيش الاوكراني وهذا السبب الاول
في وجهه نظري قائد السبب الثانيه هو ان
رجال باقر وحدهم يقاتلون في هذه الجبهه
بريجوزين عفوا اكد ان المهمه قد تستغرق
بعض الوقت وقال للجنود نصا تنظيف المنزل
طويله
اختراق الدفاع يعني اختراق الدفاع منزل
واحد ثم عليك ان تكسر دفاع المنزلي التالي
اليس كذلك هو ليس مجرد خط دفاع واحد كم
عدد خطوط الدفاع الموجوده اذا قلنا 500
فسيكون ذلك دقيقا اليس كذلك